[Music]
so I can't add a strange thing happened
this morning I woke up and you ever get
with these people oh my goodness ladies
and gentlemen this is truly a delight
and a thrill my good friend in front of
the show
comedian new material Seinfeld is here
hello new material how are you material
oh not so good Pete I need to work on
some new bits I got nobody to try them
on can I try one on you you want it yeah
I'm always happy to hear some new bits
Pete Terry why do they call them
hardwood floors this is this is the bit
what do you think I'm doing over here
Pete I don't come here for my health I
wanna listen to you rip about
Frankenstein for six minutes
[Applause]
okay so hard foot are doin Floyd's why
they call hardwood floors I don't know
that's what I am asking you why do they
call them hardwood floors they're wood
floors you know any soft wood floors
have use anybody ever complained yet I
keep falling through the floors in my
house this soft wood is too damp so just
go on floors you don't even need wood
they're all made out of wood when's the
last time you saw a metal floor said
anything is that funny
yeah I mean yeah I think he could get
their typewriters okay typewriters yeah
boy is it cold a typewriter doesn't
write ugly types just be call the
typewriter
I'm typing on the typewriter I'm doing
all the work it's taken all the credits
a lot of types of writers out there Pete
what type of writer are you I'm the type
of writer the tights on a typewriter
that's my time but right you use a
typewriter Pete that's not bad but I do
that I think that's a little bit dated
people don't really use typewriters
anymore
I'm keeping the HBO about you oh sorry
there's bars Oh hold on revolve around
bars have you noticed this Pete I'll
tell you you work hard all week your
boss is pushing you to raise the bar
oh it's Friday we need a break let's all
go to the bar the bar we're gonna have a
great time no holds barred we drink too
much get rowdy they kick us
[Music]
[Applause]
and you're behind the bar right now
you're at a bar you know I didn't notice
that
that's my god
[Applause]
[Music]